מטלסקופים ועד לגדול הנבדק חלקיקים
כל כלי מדעי חדש ישכתב את השאלות
שאנחנו כמדענים
ומוחות סקרנים יכולים לשאול בצורה סבירה
מחשוב בעל ביצועים גבוהים או HPC
הצטרף לרשימה העילית הזאת בשנות השישים היום
מחשבים קוונטיים דופקים על אותה דלת.
ברוכים הבאים שמי הוא מוביל לקפה
ואני מהנדס תוכנה כאן ב-IBM Quantum
בקורס הזה אנחנו שואפים ללמד סטודנטים
ואנשי מקצוע איך quantum computing יעבוד בקרוב
ביחד עם תשתיות HPC
כדי לספק חישוב
תלמד איך quantum
ומחשבים קלאסיים מתקשרים ומחליפים נתונים
איך לכתוב תוכניות שמנצלות את שני סוגי החומרה
ואיך האינטגרציה הזאת פותחת יישומים שאנחנו יכולים לפתור היום
תצבור ניסיון מעשי עם חומרת quantum אמיתית
ואשכולות מחשוב בעל ביצועים גבוהים קלאסיים
להרצת עבודות quantum לצד עומסי עבודה HPC מסורתיים
ולפרש תוצאות בביטחון
ולזהות מקומות שבהם האצת quantum
יכולה לעזור ממש בחישובים
ואיפה לא מעל הכל תבין
לאן עתיד המחשבים פונה
ומפת הדרכים הישנה שתוביל אותנו לשם אנחנו חושבים
שהקורס הזה חשוב
ובזמן הנכון ואנחנו מאמינים
שהשילוב של הטכנולוגיות האלה יהיה חיוני
כדי להשיג יתרון חישובי
לזה יכולות להיות השפעות רחבות על פני תעשיות
כמו כימיה שאולי תאפשר
פיתוח תרופות מהיר יותר ומחקר חומרים
בפיננסים
למודלי סיכון חכמים יותר
וגילוי הונאות בבינה מלאכותית ולמידת מכונה
לאופטימיזציה של מודלים בקורס הזה
נצלול עמוק למשאבי מחשוב
מודלי תכנות ואלגוריתמים קוונטיים
אז ברוכים הבאים ותהיו מוכנים
יש הרבה מה לדון